Riga, in Latvia, is hosting the 4th Summit
of the Eastern Partnership.
It's the meeting of the European Union with
its 6 neighbours to the east: Ukraine, Belarus,
the Republic of Moldova, Georgia, Armenia
and Azerbaijan. Since their last summit in
Vilnius the context has changed dramatically
with the conflict in Ukraine.
"We cannot escape from the sad reality of
the conflict and the daily loss of lives.
Security in Europe is at stake here. The EU
wants to offer more political and economic
cooperation to its Eastern partners.
"You have friends in Europe. You can be sure
that me, personally, and your other friends,
we will be very consistent and very loyal."
The Eastern Partnership is an offer of the
EU to its 6 neighbours. More economic support,
better administrations, modern transport and
energy networks, in exchange for democratic reform.
"Reform must continue, it must be credible,
it must be swift, it must be sustained.
You keep reforming, and we will keep supporting."
Results are tangible. Take mobility. It’s
essential, especially for youngsters.
With EU help, Moldova has passed drastic new laws
and introduced biometric passports.
Travel to the EU is now visa-free. Georgia and Ukraine
are working on it, but are not there yet.
The EU takes a one-by-one approach with its
6 Partners, each of them at its own pace.
With Belarus the focus is on human rights,
with Azerbaijan also on energy.
With Ukraine, Moldova and Georgia, the EU
last year signed Association agreements with
important trade parts. Products from these
three countries can now be sold on the EU
market without custom tax. For example: Georgia
increased its exports to the EU by 50%,
and European companies are starting to invest there.
With Armenia the situation is different. As
the country decided to join the Eurasian Economic
Union sponsored by Russia, the EU is exploring
how trade relations can be organised,
in full respect of Armenia's choice.
Let me say very clearly .... there is no way
that our partnership with our eastern partners
and countries can be perceived as confrontational,
on the contrary.... It was really clear in
the beginning and it is very clear now that
the door to cooperation is always open,
also for Russia.
Reform of the police and judiciary is crucial.
The dramatic killing of peaceful demonstrators
on Maidan Square in Kiev cannot happen again.
Citizens must be able to trust their security forces.
This is why these Ukrainian policemen are
now being trained by European colleagues on
how to handle different situations. Similar
trainings will be organised in Moldova, where
the institutions are still fragile.
"We want to assist Moldova in building resilience
to the outside and building trust at home.
An issue we will discuss further at the Eastern
Partnership Summit in Riga".
Leaders from the Eastern partnership countries
will meet in the Castle of Light, Latvia's
brand new national library on the Eastern
bank of the river Daugava.